non
m
20 minutes de marche chaque matin pour
se rendre au bureau c'est le petit
rituel qui permet à ruth copé beurre et
à son mari eric de prendre le pouls de
leur ville or les jours passent et le
pouls demeure faible
[Musique]
même les gratte-ciel emblématique de
méthane quartier d'affaires de manhattan
sont encore pour la plupart des
coquilles vides ou presque
le constat est le même lorsqu'on pénètre
dans l'édifice où se trouve le bureau de
ruth et d'éric salvail stoppé à les
autres locataires de laitages parti lors
du confinement ne sont parvenus ils sont
une centaine habituellement à warby fsb
n'a même si la mise en pause de
l'économie est terminée les travailleurs
reprennent le chemin du bureau au compte
gouttes le virus leur fait peur cette
new-yorkaise de quatrième génération
conseillère en immobilier commercial a
dû s'adapter
elle travaille maintenant chez elle à
selon un sondage du partnership for new
york céder un organisme représentant des
gens d'affaires environ 10% des employés
de bureau sont de retour le quart des
travailleurs seulement peuplera à
nouveau les tours de bureaux à la fin de
l'année et la moitié en juillet prochain
si la pandémie a paralysé la ville
l'engouement pour le télétravail laminé
davantage la location des espaces
commerciaux a fait un plongeon
vertigineux une véritable catastrophe
pour new york
les immeubles de bureaux génère près de
10 % de ses recettes fiscales
c'est tout un écosystème qui dépendent
pour survivre restaurants commerces
hôtels détaillants américains font
chaque jour ruth et eric découvre une
nouvelle fermeture une nouvelle faillite
le mexique à natori for business
des centaines de milliers d'emplois se
sont évaporés des milliards de dollars
en recettes fiscales aussi
la ville de new york déjà très endetté
ne sait plus où donner de la tête
la réduction des services commencent
déjà à se faire sentir
or la crise du coronavirus a déjà coûté
10 milliards de dollars à la ville le
maire bill de blasio a demandé à l'état
de new york
l'autorisation d'emprunter 5 milliards
de dollars pour financer les dépenses
courantes
il a menacé de licencier 22 mille
employés
des voix s'élèvent pour convaincre ou
même forcer les travailleurs à revenir
au bureau les institutions financières
commencent à réaliser que le télétravail
nuit à la productivité et les
propriétaires d'édifices devront faire
leur part pour retenir leurs locataires
décès les loyers et accepté des ententes
de plus courte durée
fini les beaux de 10 ou 20 ans
[Musique]
mais tout n'est pas sombre dans ce
portrait amazon vient d'acquérir pour un
milliard de dollars cet immeuble sur la
5e avenue
un peu plus loin facebook vient de louer
730 1000 pieds carrés séjour bannissent
tu réfléchisses à la transformation à
long terme de la ville
[Musique]
à court terme des initiatives émergent
pour donner un semblant de normalité à
la ville l'orchestré philharmonique
offre des concerts gratuits en plein air
les artistes utilisent des locaux
commerciaux vacants
l'apéritif après le travail a déjà été
plus festif pour ruth et eric il mise
sur un vaccin contre le virus
la court terme c'est très difficile elle
rêve d'une solution plus immédiate et la
vie de ceux que nous avons rencontrés à
new york a basculé mais l'adversité n'a
pas eu raison de leur combativité
[Musique]